có thương lận của thánh chả chính phủ, phíaing trì cho biết đã sả sóa và sát định số thủy giả trị giả thăng cận bộ xung
là gần mới tỷ đồng trong gia đình từ tháng 1 năm 2018 đến tháng 7 năm 2019.
Ngày bị 1 tháng 1 năm 2019, giống đặc thiết khai nộ bộ xung số thế này,
không hơn chính trăm bởi bà trụ động tiền chặn lột.
Pên trì cho biết tổng số thủy công ty và cơ công ty còn đả nổ, trong năm 2018 đến năm 2019,
là hơn năm 2019, tảm chăm 7 năm 2019.
Bảo tính mạnh ai khẩn định không quanh vì thao tổng gâm hàng để giá hát chỗ lợi.
Giống như nạn cũng cho biết đã khắp phục các thíu sóm về thối thương mạnh địa tự và phòng trống dự tiền.
Đông thời hoàn thiện quy trình quan trị đạo tạm như sự và tí tổng hạt động bình thường.
Mì ông cho biết tổn đổi dông trong cái lộn tụ thử tỷ đã được cơ quan trình năng thành trang chất năm 2018.
Không phải sự việc mới phát xanh.
Giống nghiệm đã giả sóa chứng trình và thực hiện tự yêu cầu khá phục.
Tháng tra chính phủ yêu cầu cầu cơ sân nghiệp tự thủ khá phục tiêu sóm.
Đông thời chuyển bộ công man thông tí liên quan tới việc tế khai thời vệ và lợi nhận bởi sô tiền gần chiếm tự ti đồng.